bantu's book tv
our visit to chico california continues
with local author robert cottrell as he
explores the counter culture of the
1960s and some of the influential people
and movements that helped define it the
name of my book is sex drugs and rock
and roll the rise of america's 1960s
counter culture
my book focuses on
kind of the whole of american bohemia to
a certain extent so i go back and talk
about early progenitors i talk about
figures like
edgar allan poe and walt whitman
i talk about
members of the lyrical left in the early
20th century john reed louise bryant
i talk about the hipsters
and then i focus on the beats i get two
figures of the cast of alan ginsberg and
jack kerouac who are two of the central
biographical elements in this book
and then i go on and talk about timothy
leary kankeezy
and then a whole
array of
characters who course through the decade
of the 1960s
when we think of the counter culture of
the 1960s when we think of the hippies
we think of literally millions
of participants in one capacity or
another
and they were
individuals who were
disenchanted with
matters as they were in some fashion
they were concerned about the greatest
stain on the american body republic
jim crow its continuance
they were deeply concerned about the war
in vietnam
so those are kind of two of the twin
pillars in a matter of speaking
but they were also concerned about
elemental
issues they were concerned about
family relationships
and personal dealings and
sexuality
and consciousness and rationality
and
there was this coalescing of
forces
some demographics some economic
some literary some cultural some
political in nature that
melded together and provided this kind
of backdrop
that allowed for the
counter culture of the 1960s to be as
large in scope and scale as it proved to
be there were several sparks or triggers
for the counter culture of the 1960s i
think you have the backdrop of the cold
war
internationally speaking and
domestically
unfolding simultaneously
i think you had that
feeling and that
reality of alienation that i referred to
earlier
i think the the demographic matters came
into play too you had these large pools
of young people congregating together
often on or near college university
campuses
and then you had those terrible
realities the terrible realities of
racism and war
and i think that
enabled a large number of young people
to be receptive
to
different possibilities
and then you had these
key figures
like ginsburg and kerouac
and leary and keezy but you also had
the the great bands of the era
you know
uh and the great musicians
of a more solitary cast you know from
bob dylan to the beatles to the san
francisco sound groups airplane
quicksilver grateful dead and so forth
and i think that
young people were
were drawn
to messages that were being imparted
messages of a
challenging of a probe being of a
provocative
caste
and sometimes of a of a radical nature
contesting the verities that were in
place
contesting american institutions and
even contesting
the way people
uh interacted with one another the way
people fought and the way they behaved
there's a very radical facet of the
counterculture that i that i highlight
um
there were revolutionary possibilities i
think inherent in some of this
which is why it's perceived to be as
dangerous as as it was considered by
some of the powers that were and it was
treated accordingly
um
there are other
avenues
there's the setting up of an underground
press syndicate so underground
newspapers cropped up
there's
new kind of
comics that are in in place during this
period we think of robert crum and
and
gilbert shelton and others
the rag is the underground newspaper in
in austin uh in the 1960s and i talked
about it again in that chapter on on
that
texas
capitol city
and
it was an this incredible
compendium
that publication was i mean it you can
go back and look at the issues and you
can get these snapshot looks
of so much that was going on vis-a-vis
the counterculture but the other
movements of the of the entire period
really interesting matter to reflect on
and i grapple with this as best i can in
the book
is the question of how universal in
scope and nature
the counterculture proved to be because
we think of the counter culture we think
a granite village in new york city we
think of haight ashbury in san francisco
we think of other pockets venice you
know above la and so forth
but the reality is
where young people could congregate
you could find
seeds for and then the planting of the
counterculture
which means virtually
any
college university
had the possibilities
uh inherent
in
the
fact that there was a community
of like-minded people that would be
present
so for instance one of the focal points
in one of the chapters is on austin
texas the university of texas
and people would kind of
question
why that would be included but
austin and the university of texas were
epicenters
in their own fashion for
the new left for the anti-war movement
for the counter-culture for the women's
movement
so i used that as kind of a microcosmic
examining process just as i focus on
hate not surprisingly when you get into
1967.
earlier in scope
you can talk about the
appearance at columbia university of the
small circle of friends it was referred
to in that manner it was ginsburg and
kerouac
and
their buddies
who were
challenging
the institution that was colombia and
they were challenging the literary
establishment
and they were
questioning malik as ginsburg referred
to it
as he does in his famous epic poem howl
as carorack does it on the road so
the delivery of howl which was presented
in public for the first time in 1955
the publication of on the road two years
later those are a couple of those
seminal moments
and they serve as triggers
the
appearance the
emergence of the psilocybin project at
harvard believe it or not
which involved timothy leary and then
eventually richard alpert
and
brought in
young people to serve as kind of guinea
pigs as it were
and proved to be enormously
controversial
surprisingly what became most
controversial for the august institution
that was harvard was the fact that
undergraduates were included in the mix
it seemed to be okay if it were
community members
professors or graduate students but
where harvard drew the line was with
undergraduates the mary pranksters
their journey across america in the
summer of 1964.
they went to meet kerouac in new york
city it was not a happy experience
kerouac had shifted very far to the
political right by that point in time
they went to meet
leary and alpert at millbrook estate
above new york city and that was not a
happy experience either
leary in fact didn't even greet the
pranksters even though they had gone 3
000 miles for that encounter to take
place
you get later into the the 1960s the mid
60s and the latter
portion of it all together
and it's almost like there's one event
after another
there are the anti-war protests
in
berkeley and oakland and in the bay area
in general
that involved
ginsburg and the pranksters and the
hell's angels
there are the acid test that the
pranksters put on 66
67
there's the human being
be in
in san francisco golden gate park in
january of 1967
there's the summer of love in 1967.
there's
there's woodstock there's altamonte
there's uh
the unveiling of the the family the
killings by
charles manson's
gang
in late 1969.
so
again it's it's almost as if there were
these um ethical points
that eventuated
and some
spoke to the better side
or the angelic angelic qualities
contained within the counterculture
some spoke to the darker side
um and you end up with people's own
frailties and their own weaknesses and
the
despoilation that drug usage brings
about and
all the sexually transmitted diseases
that are ushered in and
and then the lost lives
that
are such a part of the story and
you know it's we think of
the successes but
there are those who burned out along the
way i mean they're they're the famous
musicians
right who who died because of drug
overuse
correct
so you think of
in you know almost in one fell swoop
when
um
janice and jimmy and jim
died
janice joplin and jimi hendrix and jim
morrison in a matter of months 70 and 71
but there are
countless
lesser-known figures
who
their
you know education became stunted and
their occupational possibilities became
blunted
stillborn
and some of the people never recovered
they never recovered
you know their minds didn't recover and
their psyches didn't recover and their
damaged relationships were not
re-knitted
um
so there's
you know lots of serious aspects to the
to the counter culture and
some as i said before
you know seemingly were of this
millennial possib possibility wise are
some of them seemingly
reach to the stars right
in a millennial-like manner but
in some ways it was the apocalyptic
realities that
helped to
dampen
the hopes
of
how transformative this might have been
talked about this at the the near close
of the book
the computer
revolution
that we've experienced over the last few
decades the pc revolution silicon valley
at all a lot of that is believe it or
not connected with the counter culture
and
part of it is
pertaining to
who was drawn to those kinds of pursuits
and
the
the
attempt
to reach a different kind of
consciousness in different ways
and
just as the u.s
intelligence agencies and the u.s
military
helped to spawn the counterculture
believe it or not
through
drug tests
that people like
ken kesey partook off
and then helped to spread the gospel
about
um
the military is heavily involved in
birthing the computer revolution of the
the nineteen
and beyond so there's this
weird kind of symbiotic relationship
between the counter culture and
the us military and intelligence
operatives
and i'm not saying that this is a
conspiratorial in nature i'm not
suggesting that
i'm what i'm stating is the fact that
there is this
twining of these
threads
and um
that's one of the reason why the
counterculture's impact has been as
enduring as it's been
it's often been viewed in a very
character
caricatured manner
there have been cliches drawn about it
there have been stereotypes that have
been cast around it
it's largely been dismissed and
denigrated
and i think it needs to be
received and perceived for the serious
cultural
and potentially political force that it
was
um
my argument is that this was a radical
unfolding
with revolutionary
possibilities
uh did the revolution play out was
certainly not the in the manner that had
been hoped for by those who participated
in the counter culture i think that's
obviously the case
but
again
the impact nevertheless of the counter
culture
was was huge
and remains so today
book tv is on the campus of california
state university at chico this
university is the second oldest
university